avant d'accueillir camille combal on va
jouer au gros jeux le gros jeu c'est
très simple voilà il ya quatre personnes
qui jouent vous jouez également chez
vous qui me when you pay oui s'il vous
plaît je vous posais une question sur la
télé mais une question très très simple
pour répondre vous devrez effectuer une
action pour pouvoir beuzit d'accord vous
fait l'action et vous posez ensuite
d'accord attention je vous le dis la
première action c'est donc prendre le
petit suisse vous attention mais je ne
peux pas vous salir c'est à dire vous le
mettez la bam et vous essayez d'abord
connaissez ça marche comme je voulais
que j'essaie de vous le faire oui alors
elle tombait encore d'oreille ah oui on
le mail à chaque fois ça tombe sur la
gueule
voilà c'est ça vas-y jamais réussi
[Rires]
c'est un peu de repos
[Applaudissements]
tom emploi
manager présente nagui sur france 2 tous
les jours à midi
attention mesdames et l'a pas fait mais
là pour lever la troupe mais tu prends
la place vient pas du tout le monde veut
prendre sa place
[Applaudissements]
selon lui tout le monde veut prendre sa
place très bonne réponse je prenais
chacun un petit verre les chéris c'est
de l'aunis et de l'huile de foie de
morue
c'est très bon vous inquiétez pas ça
m'étonnerait salopards avant de baisser
les bras
ça fait quoi dire vous allez voir vous
allez voir attention attention je pose
la question c'est de lui qu'elle
attention voici la question sur quelle
chaîne est diffusée l'émission crime de
jean-marc nrj 12
voilà
il va falloir mettre tous les chamallows
dans la bouche faut répondre
attention attention attendait voici la
question aimez moi j'ai mis dans savoir
que je fais comme celle de quelle
émission de télé dans quelle émission de
télé poteau voir les candidats triche
sur play cpj il en pousse des tricheurs
à pape diop et dans quelle émission de
télé peut-on voir les candidats retirer
des couteaux d'un fourreau sur m6 vous
avez tous ces mecs là là
mais vous
alors
[Applaudissements]
juste un mec qui kiffe le chamallow
boisé
j'adore cela bref de quoi vous madame
vous madame c'est non qu'est ce que les
voix s'élèvent qu'à gagner voilà bah je
vous le dis bravo pas être bon